ora o uso pessoal de 20 mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer manchado
muito princípio que o que vocês viram no
jogo ar só escolher e maio vão precisar
de usar folhas como se fossem rifas e
que nos deixa feliz
afinal prendam quem fica por não celular
tudo nesta parte inicial vão gostar de
quatro pulinhos não tem 2002 usando fita
e só fita usem cola cola não da amur
assistência para estudar porque para
fazer o carro cair depois você tirar
aquelas parte mais pequeninas e que
pouco resistentes vão juntar os dois de
um lado as outras duas do outro
nobre é uma e ajustar o tamanho pra
ficarem quase não sabe voar mais duas
folhas mesmo marcar em maio das duas
polícias começa é mudar parte do lâmina
e estou fazer lâmina mas a gente precisa
é comum machado jogo essas críticas
claro vocês podem fazer como vocês
quiserem aqui nesta parte para não ficar
contigo de vocês dobram para dentro e
prendem com fita e na na altura vocês
brincarem não tem que ter um cuidado com
essa partida ok
apesar não ser assim tão ponte aguda e
se vocês forem crianças que melhor você
usar os óculos de proteção que segurança
nunca é demais não cair pois prender uma
gota dentro da outra aparecem duas gotas
eu vou encaixar o cabo e vão ajustando
aos poucos para ver como fica melhor
para vocês vocês viram que eu ia lá e
três vezes e é só encaixar o livro de
confiar
vai que você aperta e vai pra ficar
resistente
justo do outro lado e fazer mesmo que só
é base de uma chapa que só é parte
rígida partida que vocês conseguem fazer
uma customização muito boa
podem usar aquelas fitas usadas pelos
pintores do papel não vou revelando a
volta e sendo a fita do papel consegue
pintar em cima dela muito vai vocês
quiserem dar uma textura podem usar colo
quinta caiu no colo hoje para a textura
por aparecer mesmo cabo de madeira para
o desafio
então se tiver aquelas correntes meninas
não fique bhanji zoológico frente tal
assim e foi fechado antes um bio sei lá
por causa do gênio mas quando o objetivo
era mesmo estado como fazer a base e só
os carros o fim os pés amputados e se
vocês quiserem usar o canal da rocinha
inscrevam para acompanhar as coisas que
eu faço e deixem os comentários mais
sugestões é só ligar o intestino e até à
próxima champions